la ciudad es ucranianas siguen bajo
ataque durante la noche un asalto con
misiles rusos golpeó la ciudad de
greenboyrock en el centro del país un
edificio Residencial fue alcanzado
ha ocurrido una tragedia en la ciudad
varios cohetes cayeron destruyendo
instalaciones industriales algunas
estructuras y viviendas tras horas de
emergencia todavía hay víctimas bajo los
escombros según las autoridades
ucranianas
estábamos durmiendo todas las ventanas
fueron destrozadas aún no entiendo cómo
ocurrió todo al principio hubo un fuerte
estruendo los coches se incendiaron la
ventana de aquí saltó por los aires fue
terrible
Mientras tanto en el terreno de los
combates el ejército ucraniano Afirma
estar avanzando y recuperando
territorios como estos soldados
celebrando la reconquista del pueblo de
macaríptica donde aún persisten algunos
enfrentamientos
desde el sábado cuando fue el anuncio
oficial de la contraofensiva ucraniana 7
aldeas habrían sido reconquistadas según
Jeff un éxito para el presidente
agradezco a nuestros soldados por cada
bandera ucraniana que ahora está
volviendo a su lugar legítimo en los
pueblos del territorio recientemente
liberado
por su parte Moscú considera que la
contraofensiva de kiev ha sido un
fracaso hasta el momento las tropas
rusas mostraron la toma de tanques
leopard donados por Alemania como prueba
de ello y el Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia afirmó que sus tropas han repetido
los avances ucranianos en las regiones
de donets y saporicha